hello and welcome to this video playing
do to probably I mean he's got pretty
high rating doesn't happen all that
often that I get players here they're
higher rated on him he declined he
declined the banker with b68 is a five
rook a for is usually not believed to be
very critical would seem one reason is
that black is getting this Bishop b5 IDN
to trade the Bishop doesn't mind that at
all I mean okay he didn't have anything
better really
I would absolutely like to play 98 c7 b5
and they will probably do that next
I just wanted to add some additional
oops pressure on the b-pawn yes so I'm
going to do that now I wonder if Bishop
g5 is an idea somehow just checking a
seven
I know B twist giving away but not
probably not yeah he's going for it
but if I'm into this it looks a little
bit odd but SL f 9 c 7 B 5 and now B 2
is hanging he gets root B 1 in of this
one okay
night maybe five now really a bit odd
all this
I wanted to do this
now trying to trade off the night on v6
hmm very very tough position
I mean he definitely would like to not
trade I think I'm not sure that night
see for this one I need to get rid of
that night so that rook c8 becomes
possible okay I've got Knight c3 or
Bishop c3 ideas let's do this first
comes right in tonight a4 which does not
probably matter or that much maybe maybe
in fact if I go here I've got Knight to
c4 which attacks b6 and the bishop if I
can get the bishop I will probably get
the pawn like rook c5 will be 5 these
these kind of things
okay here I also have rook c3 which is
probably not leading to all that much
Quinn before they don't have a good two
moves
I cannot check
Jim
that's really tough really tough 92 see
for a 5 or something yeah that is why
you take with this I waiting with the
pawn
you know Jim that wasn't good I have no
clue where this totally I mean I have to
be very okay after the opening there's
no doubt about that like here here only
if anybody black can be better but it
didn't it didn't at all can the engine
is equal I'm okay with that assessment
we white certainly has no advantage but
it went belly up really really quickly
and somehow
yeah Bishop g5 and five is a really cool
solution but okay this one night a forum
to so might be six eight yeah I look a
for and then before some mmm of course
good when you get it in a night a eight
I thought about but I underestimated how
good before well yes I mean I was it was
pretty clear that this is a move of
course what
yeah I know I wanted that b5 looked okay
to me and then 97 I wanted to work with
the C's risking his before but it never
did not really have a materialized
take-take-take we should be three yeah
maybe I should not take it see max
it's all simpler 394 ammonium just lost
him I just lost him FTX of course also
was found
yeah perfect game by what what can you
do I mean this is one of those zero zero
zero games maybe maybe white made one
inaccurate move but that is the extent
of it before was better than UK for but
extremely strong game here by white I
think I don't think it the engine will
find many flaws in whites the whites
play so the key thing was I had to play
Knight AAA it right at this at this
moment this was the only this was
inaccurate by my white rook f4 and said
before was strongly and I have to go
night at eight and then I then I'm fine
in this position again general I never
really think this is so much for what
you have traded to the bishop which is
very helpful and generally speaking
white has extremely I mean as many
weaknesses b3p 284 and so on so it
cannot be a better for white if black is
precise but I wasn't precise enough that
is a really a bit better but I didn't
really see you in the game or I don't
know it did not really registers that I
have this and I also underestimated how
good before early as I mean it wasn't
killing me right away but it was
certainly an improvement for white him a
improvement yeah thanks a lot for
watching